stop making excuses so I just got off a
call with a friend of mine who teaches
people to communicate better and one of
her core messages is to be vulnerable to
not be perfect all the time to show
people a little bit of humanity because
if you want your message to get out
there you are much more likely to
connect with people when they see that
you are not perfect that you have weak
spots and that you're willing to be
vulnerable and let people touch those
soft spots on you because it's going to
make them understand your message and
listen to you more so this is a perfect
opportunity because I'm on this video
call with her and she just had this
surgery on her face to remove some dark
spots or whatever and she she looks like
she just came out of a star trek movie
she's got stuff all over her face and I
said this is your chance right now you
need to make a movie a video right now
about vulnerability you got to show up
get on camera and say you need to be
vulnerable just like I am right now I'm
a vain person I want to look good and
here i am with this stuff all over my
face and I'm willing to get on camera so
you should too if she wants her clients
to really listen to that message of
vulnerability then she needs to be
vulnerable in that moment too I've had
so many people who who I want to you
know put on camera that oh no I can't
you know I've got this I got this pit
bull here somewhere buried above my
forehead and I i I'm not gonna look good
I can't do that I've done videos with
hickeys on my neck with pimples all over
the place what am i doing I don't even
know what I'm wearing right now you
gotta be vulnerable you gotta be willing
to put yourself out there and that's
that's the opportunity so for my friend
right now she comes up with this excuse
okay and she tells me yeah that's my
message but but sometimes I also agree
that you have to look professional and
Evan you know i look at your videos and
you're always in your black shirt that
says believe when you always look great
and it's super polished and professional
we'll look at me now this one's for you
still doing videos
so get out there for my friend you know
who you are record that video on
vulnerability because now is the time to
do it and for all of you who are too
afraid who are coming up with excuses
for things that you know you want to do
but you're putting off because you find
some reason you're waiting for the
perfect time there will be no perfect
time so stop worrying stop coming with
excuses and start doing believe you guys
like this video you want to see more
like it subscribe to the channel saying
thanks thanks so much for watching I'll
see you soon hi I'm tourism from time
management chef calm and Uncle Mike this
new center ethic subscribe
you